hallo liebe zuschauer sind zurück in
münster mit einer weiteren episode für
euch unser heutiges thema ist
gleichzeitig sprachlich wie auch
philosophisch interessant und zwar
wollen wir wissen wie definieren
menschen hier in münster das wort arbeit
los geht's
christoph kannst du uns das wort arbeit
definieren wie würdest du das wort
arbeit beschreiben
ich glaube dass das also wenn es jetzt
nur um mich geht dann wäre das für mich
eine positive beschäftigung also etwas
was ein beschäftigt und das haben damit
meine ich vom kopf her und natürlich
auch physisch im zweifel ich glaube das
ist aber sehr viele unterschiedliche
definitionen von arbeit gibt deswegen
bin ich sehr gespannt auf diese folge
arbeit arbeit ist der broterwerb der
lebensunterhalt dem man sich verdient
durch irgendeine tätigkeit die einem im
besten fall spaß macht besteht aus weg
und zeit
definieren also arbeit definiert als
etwas das anstrengend ist
deswegen mögen dass manche leute nicht
und man muss immer zeit investieren
dabei immer einen weg zurücklegen
arbeit arbeit ist für mich eigentlich
jetzt einen heutigen sinne quasi etwas
womit ich mein brot verdienen damit ich
leben kann es aspekte auf der einen
seite gehört zu einem leben dazu dass
ich meinen beitrag leisten damit das
kann sich selbst also lebens möglich
wird
zum zweiten gibt aber auch zu mir dazu
denn wenn ich keine arbeit hätte wäre
ich ohne arbeit wie er selbst in meinem
alter ich bin 78 wenn ich keine aufgaben
hätte wirklich für mich das leben nicht
lohnen
kein punkt kann positiv seien die arbeit
je nachdem was ich für eine arbeit mache
hausarbeit wo ich putze ich das lied
daher alles schön sauber ist arbeit
arbeit ist sich mühe geben
und naja vielleicht wird man dafür
bezahlt manchmal als bussen nicht
unbedingt sein
für etwas ganz viel kraft und mühe
investieren etwas notwendiges zum
überleben
ich schreibe meine masterarbeit und das
ist echt die geistige arbeit und dass es
so anstrengend
wirklich und da denkt man hätte hier ist
doch nur ein buch kann doch nicht so
kaputt davon seien
ich brauche schon etwas wenn ich eine
arbeit habe muss ich mich auch schon ein
intro mit identifizieren können aber ich
glaube in unserer heutigen zeit das ist
auch schwierig da durch zu halten bis
das man an diesem punkt angekommen ist
das ein job finde es mit dem du dich
auch wirklich identifizieren kannst und
anstrich halt arbeit arbeitet eine
beschäftigung um den lebensunterhalt zu
verdienen kann es auch mehr sein
ja klar nicht nur die arbeit im sinne
des berufes auf die alltägliche arbeit
da geht es nicht um geld verdienen immer
es gibt arbeit die kostet nicht viel
zeit die muss man aber lange vorbereiten
renovieren
das anstreichen selber dauert vielleicht
zwei stunden aber die vorbereitungen
mindestens drei oder drei tage ja das
wort arbeit das was ich den ganzen tag
machen
von heute bis morgen von heute morgen
bis heute abend in die bibliothek sitzen
macht spaß
ja sind sie sich ja nicht tun ja arbeit
macht auch glücklich wenn sie erfüllt
aber ich hab schon jobs gehabt so die
hardcore zentren jobs oder sowas da muss
ich ganz explizit sagen das ist ja das
möchte ich nie wieder für mein leben
haben geld damit zu verdienen also etwa
aufzuschwatzen hat ist nicht mein nähe
nicht meine philosophie arbeite ja so
was mich betrifft arbeite ich gerne weil
ich mit engagement das mache also das
ist für mich arbeitet also für mich ist
es positiv summe und die frage des
geldes ist sekundär ob sich das ist spaß
macht das ist ja ich bin ich werde
lehrerin für gesundheitsberufe da war
sprengmeister also dafür mache ich die
maßarbeit
daher bin ich auch gesundheit zur
krankenpflegerin es ist ein ganz
anstrengender beruf bei dem man immer zu
wenig zeit hat wohl wieder aber derzeit
sind alle bewegen können sie über die
jahre gemacht auf einer intensivstation
und die arbeit kann aber auch sehr
erfüllen wenn man ein tolles team hat
mit dem mann zusammen was geboten
bekommt und
wenn man viel zurückbekommt also man
fällt winter nicht viel geld aber es ist
einen job in dem man viel anerkennung
erhält
ich hoffe das was als lehrerin auch mal
so sein
dabei warten aber gespannt wie ihr für
den untertitel gewuppt übersetzt ich
auch bestimmt links sowie sehen andere
leute die wir in andere das definieren
ich glaube dass es für viele menschen
notwendiges übel ist um sich ein leben
zu finanzieren
das ist ja so die grundfrage nach leben
um zu arbeiten oder arbeiten um zu leben
ich glaube ich bin eher so leben um zu
arbeiten weil ich nicht so klar trennen
zwischen dem was ich privat mache was
ich beruflich mache also ich glaube
schon dass ich meine leidenschaft auch
irgendwo zum beruf gemacht habe arbeit
glaube ich dass man beschäftigt ist in
einer art und weise die man nur binding
freiwillig macht etwas negatives arbeit
die man freilich muss also wenn man es
nicht freiwillig macht heißt ja nicht
dass es direkt negativ ist kann trotzdem
spaß machen aber man macht es aus einem
bestimmten grund
vergnügen bereiten soll
völlig in geistige anstrengung
ich will so kracht und daraus eine
formel oder arbeit gleich kraft mal
minuten oder so richtig ehrlich wie
viele zimmer arbeitet spaß macht
definitiv ich gehe gleich zur arbeit und
ich freue mich total darauf mit dem team
sammelte als kennerin und das macht spaß
das macht total spaß den leuten die
leute glücklich zu machen und eine coole
kollege liebe leute das war's für heute
wir hoffen es hat euch gefallen mal ein
wort definition mit ein bisschen
philosophischen touch dahinter erzählt
ihr uns doch mal was für euch arbeit
bedeutet dass wir uns jetzt
interessieren und danke noch mal fürs
zuschauen
danke für eure unterstützung bei patchen
wenn ihr uns auch unterstützen möchte
dann guckt mal bei kathrein und misst
der link wir freuen uns sehr über jeden
der unser programm unterstützt danke
fürs zuschauen und bis zur nächsten
woche
heute.de